- [Kelly] : Welcome back!
We're here with the cast of Black Adam:
Dwayne Johnson, Pierce
Brosnan, Aldis Hodge,
Quintessa Swindell, and Noah Centineo.
Well, if there's one group
of people truly passionate
about their fandom,
it's comic book readers.
They love you or hate you, it's like.
So we, we thought we'd let the cast
field some of those fans'
questions with a Black Adam round
of Ultimate Twitter Questionnaire.
(upbeat music)
♪ It's Kelly's Ultimate
Twitter Questionnaire. ♪
(audience applause)
- Thank you, Marcell.
- Oh, we got a button?
- Okay, so.
- Noah likes buttons.
- What happens... Yeah, you
can't, I'm gonna do the button.
I'm gonna hold it down.
So what happens, and
it's so sophisticated.
So I'm gonna hit this button,
on our super random super computer.
It only has one button, so,
you know, I don't have many choices.
So then, then the computer
will search Twitter
for a question about Black Adam
that the cast has to answer.
You have to.
(Kelly chuckles)
This is rapid fire.
Ready? Here we go.
(screen chiming)
(bell dings)
Question for Dwayne Johnson:
What is Black Adam's favorite
Dwayne Johnson movie?
(all laughing)
So?
- Oh man, um.
- Inquiring minds want to know.
- I would say Black Adam's favorite
No. God can't right now is
- you can't, Yeah, you
can't say Black Adam,
you have to say something else. Yeah yeah.
- I made a movie one time
with my wife that I can't,
no, nevermind. Sorry.
(audience laughs)
(cast laughs and chatters)
- It was all going so well.
It was all going so well.
(laughing and chattering)
- The amount of time it
took for me to get that
was like, I was like, I literally, if
they play back my face,
I went, that's sweet.
And then I go oh. (laughter)
- That would probably
be a good, don't brag.
Okay. What's your favorite?
(Laughing)
- That's all I got. No.
Yeah. Next question.
I'm only kidding. I'm only kidding.
- You have so many. Just pick one.
- Uh, Okay. Uh.
- Jumanji, just pick it.
- Jumanji? Yes. That it.
- [Kelly, Singsong] Jumanji.
- Jumanji.
Okay, Okay. Just pick
it. I just threw one out.
I was like you got so many great ones.
OK, here we go. Boom. Okay.
- Oh my God.
(computer rings)
(ding)
- If you could alter
this size of your body
like Atom Smasher, how would
you use that power for good?
- I'm gonna answer it
differently than Dwayne.
- Okay.
(Laughing)
- You mean classic?
(Laughter)
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah. It's not good.
It's not bad. It's just different.
- That's a question about altering size.
- Oh my God, okay go.
- I would get cats outta trees.
- You'd get cats outta, oh.
You're like a fireman. I like it.
- Is that right? Cats outta trees?
- That's right. That's how I, that's
what I would do.
- Dirtiest player in the game,
he's gonna get cats outta trees.
- Okay, wait. Next one,
next one. Here we go.
(computer rings)
(dings)
Okay, If black Adam is
willing to hurt anyone
can anyone really trust him?
Can he ever have any true friends?
This got real dark. Woo.
- Well, I'm not gonna, I, You guys answer.
- No? Do you think?
Well, well you should answer.
- Go ahead.
- If he is willing to hurt anyone.
You know what?
I don't feel like Black Adam
is willing to hurt anyone.
I feel like black Adam, as
a protector, is gonna hurt
Who might need to get a little slap down.
So to protect the people
that need to be protected.
So yes, he can have true friends.
- Okay. You should be in politics.
How that was just
navigated was so well done.
- Beautifully
- I'm gonna start running
my campaign to go, so just
vote for your boy when you
see me pop up and stuff.
Yeah.
- Okay. That's our ultimate
Twitter Questionnaire.
This is what we learned today.
(Audience applause)
- A big thanks to the
whole case and everyone
in the audience will want
to thank them as well
because they're sending you home
with a pair of tickets to
see Black Adam in IMAX.
(Audience Cheering)
The movie hits theater's Friday,
You do not wanna miss it. Go watch it.